I'm Fiona Alvarez former member of ABBA
oh I I guess always a member of ABBA
I'm standing right here in the heart of
the Abba Museum in Stockholm
and here people tend to stay for a while
looking at the outfits and and all those
vinyl records that we have from all
around the globe here
you cannot pay your entry with cash here
you know Sweden we have our own currency
and we are very very quick to adapt to
new technology Sweden would be the ideal
country
to make cashless
the whole thing began because my son was
burgled and I thought to myself what
would happen in a cashless Society what
would they do
with that computer that smartphone
if it cannot be transformed into Cash
the deeper I've gotten into it the more
I think that it will add benefits to a
society that goes cashless and I want to
find out what those benefits could be I
wanted to make an example and then I
thought that this Museum should be
cashless
I mean today is digital anyway and we're
going that direction whether we want it
or not take away the paper and take away
the metal
nothing's gonna happen it is a symbol
it's an abstract symbol there is a
museum in Stockholm where they can go
and look at coins and bills I think that
should be the future of money in the
museum